hello suit sheep welcome to the seven
million Habits of Highly Effective
Hampton DeVille employment number 911
it's important to keep your professional
life separate from your personal life
even if you work side by side but the
person that you have secret feelings for
it's important to not ever let those
feelings see the light of day no
inappropriate touching do not invite it
upon yourself do not do that case we're
inflicted on someone else yes this would
be an exam you would never know that and
I know it's wrong because it feels good
yeah don't do that please don't I like
to think of my feelings as living
breathing human being that is so
poignant Kate and in order to maintain
professionalism at work it's critical
that you bury that human deep deep under
the earth in a coffin no matter how much
they beg and scream and plead to be let
out you never kissed a co-worker
do not do that don't do it we have never
done never think about it either never
didn't happen
silly goose
you